now in question five people who pursue
careers in transportation planning have
a wide variety of educational
backgrounds that she feels pretty good I
don't know if I would change that at all
but let's let's see what the other
choices are people who pursue careers in
transportation planning have a wide
variety of educational backgrounds when
you put these commas around who pursue
careers in transportation planning it
makes it look like hey that's that's
just you know that's that's something
that doesn't have to be part of the
sentence it's a sometimes people would
say it's an a non-restrictive clause
it's a clause that doesn't it kind of
tells you another way of thinking about
people it's an optional thing but for
this sentence we don't want it we
couldn't just say people have a wide
variety of educational backgrounds even
though that is true people do have a
wide variety of educational backgrounds
that go that's not what the the meaning
of the sentence is it's very important
that we talk about what type of people
people who pursue careers in
transportation planning so I guess one
way to you could call it is this is a
very important restrictive clause for
this sentence you need to know what type
of people that is key to the meaning of
the sentence so I wouldn't I wouldn't
put them I wouldn't put commas around it
which makes you feel that it's a it's
it's optional it's another way of
describing the people maybe you could
just read people have a wide variety of
educational backgrounds so I don't like
this I think for the for the meaning
that we are trying to give that the
writer is trying to give it's very
important that you have who pursue
careers in transportation planning not
have commas once again the commas make
it sound like you're it's just another
way of describing people not essential
necessarily to the meaning of the
sentence but this is essential to the
meaning of sentence people who pursue
careers in transportation planning have
a wide variety of education backgrounds
well this is kind of doing something
similar now they're just putting in
transportation planning in comas and if
one way to think about that is you could
say like people who pursue careers have
a wide variety of educational background
well that's a true statement but this
whole passage is about people who pursue
careers in transportation planning you
don't want to you don't want to just
like we said for be you don't want to
mark this off you don't want to mark
this off with a with this clause making
it seem like this this clause is kind of
optional you need to say in
transportation planning so I wouldn't
put commas around it and then finally
people who pursue careers in
transportation planning comma have a
wide variety of educational backgrounds
well that just feels that that's you
we're just taking the kind of the the
subject of the sentence and separating
it from the predicate of the sentence
with a comma four for some reason so
that doesn't make any sense so i would
definitely go out no change there's no
commas in it people who pursue careers
in transportation planning have a wide
variety of educational backgrounds and
then we could keep reading but obviously
if you're an under time pressure for the
s.a.d you wouldn't necessarily have to
read all of this but between answering
all these questions I it's nice to be
able to read all this a two-year degree
in transportation technology may be
sufficient for some entry-level jobs in
the field most jobs however require at
least a bachelor's degree majors of
transportation planners are varied
majors of transportation planners are
varied including fields such as Urban
Studies civil engineering geography or
transportation and logistics management
for many positions in the field a
master's degree is required so once
again if you were doing this passage you
wouldn't really have to read all of this
you could have just tackled the sentence
by itself but if you have the time it
doesn't hurt to you might learn
something about career of transportation
planning